I want to play a clip for you that's
been viewed more than 26 million times
if anything kills over 10 million people
in the next few decades its most likely
to be a highly infectious virus rather
than a war not missiles but microbes
that was Bill Gates back in 2015
five years ago warning about precisely
the kind of threat we're all facing
right now
since then Gates has been doing
everything he can to prevent a pandemic
two months ago the Gates Foundation
committed 100 million dollars to fight
the corona virus earlier I sat down with
Bill Gates to discuss what we need to do
now bill it took four months to reach
half a million cases around the world
and just seven days to add another half
million cases so how dangerous how
fearsome is this virus and how do you
see this epidemic playing out in the US
well this is a nightmare scenario
because human human transmissible
respiratory viruses can grow
exponentially and you know if we had
kept on going to work traveling like we
were you know that curve would never
Bend until you had the majority of the
people infected and then a massive
number seeking hospital care and lots
and lots of deaths so you know we've had
to use quarantine which is a you know
old thing back from the days of the
plague as our primary tool fortunately
if we use that well enough we should
towards the end of this month start to
see those numbers level off and then if
we continue countrywide and we're
testing the right people to understand
what's going on which it's not the case
yet those numbers will start to go down
and then we can look at some degree of
opening back up president
top health advisors are talking about
somewhere between a hundred and two
hundred forty thousand deaths over the
next two months does that sound about
right to you in terms of the lethality
and the length of the outbreak here in
the US well we do the social distancing
properly we should be able to get out of
this with the death number well short of
that it's very important that those
numbers are out there because a lot of
people are still thinking hey isn't like
normal not waking up every day to a
completely new reality and so I was very
glad that those models are out there you
know doctor foul she's doing a very good
job of saying the numbers are what count
here and you know the various models
that we Imperial University do show that
without this dramatic behavior change
you could even get worse than that but I
do think if we get the testing fixed we
get all 50 states involved we'll be
below that of course we'll pay a huge
economic price in order to achieve that
you say that if we do everything right
now in terms of testing and shutting the
country down that we should have only
one wave of this virus why are you so
confident because a lot of people are so
sure that we're not going to have a
recurrence when we get another flu
season next fall well we don't know how
seasonal this virus is you know it'd
probably be good for the northern
hemisphere if the force of infection
goes down as we get into spring and
summer you know and give us some time to
get both the drugs and advance of the
vaccine it's it is fair to say things
won't go back to truly normal until we
have a vaccine that we've gotten out to
basically the entire world and so you
know the best people at the foundation
who are all about high-volume vaccines
you know are working with many
manufacturers not only on the safety
napkin
but getting that billions of dose
capacity and so like China there'll be a
partial opening up which some jobs will
resume school will resume but we'll have
to be very very careful not to have the
rebound
until the vaccine comes now you talk
about the foundation all the way back on
February 5th the Gates Foundation
committed 1 million dollars to fight
this virus but you point out the fact
that the our government like a lot of
other governments was very slow to
respond really it another two months we
might have lost how much did that cost
does in terms of the spread of this
disease that that one or two months that
we lost well there are countries like
Taiwan who were exemplary saw the
problem and really got the testing
community-wide testing done very well
they prioritized who got tested and so
they won't either have the disease
burden or the economic effect that other
countries will have China by late
January had taken it seriously and so
you know their ability to get the cases
to come down spend dramatic South
Korea's on that and so there are lessons
that we're learning from and you know
we're all in this together we've got to
get rid of coronavirus from the entire
world you know the US we can see how
tough it is here likely it'll be even
worse in the developing countries who is
yet don't have nearly as many cases how
do you think the federal and state
governments are responding now and would
you prefer to see it all being handled
on a national level whether it stay at
home orders or testing where the supply
chain would you prefer to see this all
being handled on a national centralized
level rather than state-by-state well
when you have finite resources you need
to allocate them to where there's the
most need certainly the because people
move around the country we have to have
the shut down or else you'll have
exponential growth that will spread back
into other parts of the
country in terms of testing people have
got confused and think it's just about
numbers the key is that you have a
response to the test in less than 24
hours and that you're prioritizing the
right people and so although the numbers
are going up we're not yet focusing in
on that you know medical personnel or
somebody who's keeping the electric
network for the food distribution
working and being able to say if
somebody test positive very quickly
tests their contacts and so you know I
do think you know that allocation
prioritization of testing will be a key
tactic for us to get into good shape and
that needs to be done at a national
level not a state level that's right I
mean you have some states that it just
happens the number of PCR machines in
that state are very few and you wouldn't
think hey that's the way this this
should be done and also the outbreak you
know is bigger in in some areas and so
therefore that drives the the testing
demand likewise the ventilator demand I
mean this is all very ad hoc because we
never did a full-blown simulation there
were a few a few things done but it's
not like war where we do war games all
the time we have people standing by
resources and buying a dramatic level
you know we're kind of figuring this out
as we go which you know people are
rising to the occasion and you know it's
fantastic to see that but you know every
day we can see that case number is still
going on when you gave that famous TED
talk five years ago you laid out a lot
of the things that we're starting to do
now like research and development on new
tests and R&D on vaccines but so many
countries around the world including the
u.s. back in 2015 largely ignored your
warnings why do you think that was well
there's it's hard to put money into
something where you don't know
if it's gonna happen we do for fires
because you know we've seen that over
time we do for war in fact you know 600
billion a year in that case what would
have been required you know it's nothing
like that you know the ability to make a
test super quickly the ability to know
how a library of drugs that would work
for this ability to have the vaccine
very quickly I am sure after this which
is just such a gigantic impact that we
will put that money in but between 2015
and 2020 less than 5% of what should
have been done was done but people
didn't get that this is the biggest
single threat that you know could
disrupt our way of life which you know
even having predicted that as a risk I'm
really stunned at how you know tough it
is to go through this you know the
medical cost the economic cost the
psychological cost everybody's lives
have been completely upended and and
that's not just the United States it's
it's almost the entire world well let me
ask you personally about that Bill and
Melinda Gates I think it's fair to say
are not your typical American family but
how has this virus this epidemic how has
it upended your life and how personally
are you dealing with and processing what
we're going through now well I'm you
know a lot more isolated the meetings
are on software Microsoft teams you know
I I even friends that I would normally
go see you know we're doing video
conferencing which seems a bit unusual
you know there's a lot of anxiety about
you know how far does this go we have
employees of the foundation who feel a
bit isolated you know because they're
just in our apartment somewhat they're
kids they're feel like it's very crowded
so how do we help people deal with this
you know they a lot of people are rising
the occasion but you know I for me you
know my life is just completely
different I wake up every morning and
think is this real or was it something I
had a nightmare about and like all the
rest of us I mean do you get scared
sometimes and if so about what well this
isn't the worst case that is the 1% or
so case fatality rate when your medical
system is not overloaded if this was
smallpox that would be like 30% so this
is super super bad but you know we we
will eventually get a vaccine even
before then if we do the right things
we'll be able to open up significant
parts of the economy and you know so
once you're in the crisis you're just
doing your best to deal with it I'm sure
you know once we get past this we'll
look back understand what we could have
done differently and make sure that
we're not letting it happen again
particularly because it could be even
worse
in terms of the fatality rate Bill Gates
next time you give one of these speeches
I hope I trust people will listen thank
you so much thank you